the uk now has enough coronavirus
vaccine to give
five doses to every person in the
country
four different experimental jabs are
already in the stockpile
but the risk is so high that at least
one will fail during clinical trials
that the government has now bought two
more prototypes
as an insurance what it brings us is a
portfolio of
six different vaccines across four
different types of vaccine format
so we have now assembled our core
portfolio of different vaccines because
we don't know
if any of these different vaccines will
work and we want to be sure
that if any one vaccine is shown to be
safe and effective
that we have access to it so that we can
vaccinate and protect those who are most
at risk
from covered infection the uk's
stockpile is now one of the world's
largest the new deals are for 60 million
doses from the u.s
biotech firm novovax and 30 million from
the belgian pharmaceutical company
johnson johnson
they add to the 250 million doses
of four other vaccines already ordered
with
options on another 40 million that's a
total
of 380 million doses
but the global jostling for a vaccine
threatens to leave poorer countries
behind
gabby the vaccine alliance told sky news
fair global access
will end the pandemic more quickly our
fundamental belief is that
no one is safe so a different view is to
say
let's try to get vaccines out to the
world
let's try to vaccinate the most
vulnerable
and important groups in those countries
and that'll dampen down the global
pandemic
and then as we have access to more
vaccines we can build on that
the government insists it is
contributing to global access
and johnson johnson says the early
commitment from the uk
gives it the confidence to push ahead
with expensive clinical trials
if all goes well the vaccine should be
ready next spring
we count that it will take at least
until the end of the year to complete
the study
if not until january february
and then let's say the first quarter
conclude on data in the second quarter
next year starting april we should be
able to
vaccinate on a large scale the
government won't say how much the uk's
stockpile has cost
but is likely to be well over a billion
pounds
money that will be lost if the vaccines
fail
but the economic losses from the
pandemic are so great
that it would consider the risk well
worthwhile
thomas more sky news